[Music]
[Applause]
all right Let's Make Way for
the goat Chris Mannix Sports Illustrated
senior writer covering the NBA Playoffs
he was at game one with Atlanta and
Boston he'll be there game two tonight
then he heads to the West Coast for a
Clippers game and the Lakers game three
and Mannix joins us on the program what
did you see in the Draymond Green play
I understand
why the referees threw him out because
it did meet the criteria for excessive
it was by the letter of the law of
flagrant foul2 but that was one of those
moments where I really wish the referees
would have shown some discretion there
because
we can watch it 50 times on replay and
we can see Draymond stepping on De
Montes sabonis
but
In the Heat of that moment that play and
that sequence doesn't happen unless the
bonus grabs the leg of Draymond Green
and sure draymond's got to be smarter
but in that moment Dan fourth quarter
close game Draymond grabs a rebound and
is going back the other way to try to
put this team up in transition
I I just felt there should have been a
little bit of leeway
to keep Draymond in the game you know
give him a flagrant one call it
technical on him as well call a personal
foul on him as well call anything on him
but just don't toss him out of the game
and I thought it was telling Dan when
TNT went to Monty McCutchen who is the
tsar of NBA referees who is always
full-throated support of his referees
and their decisions Monty McCutchen the
first thing he said was you know
difficult play you know difficult play
to make a decision on so
I I just wish there had been more of a
Runway to punish Draymond for what he
did but also keep him in a critical game
priors how does that factor in with
Draymond Green in a situation like that
I'm sure it does and as we sit here on
Tuesday
you know I certainly will wonder if the
NBA decides to suspend him I suspect not
because I think the NBA you know given
the benefit of you know 12 hours will
you know probably see what everyone saw
which is a you know a bang bang moment
where Draymond you know got tangled up
and intentionally by the way you know he
was grabbed by sabonis uh and the NBA
will decide not to suspend him but look
Draymond is not going to get the benefit
of the doubt when it comes to
to these types of plays he's got too
much of a history of doing it for the
referees to to show him that kind of
respect uh bigger picture here
Steph's never been down O2 in a playoff
series now you're going back home
now you got to win the next two to put
the pressure on Sacramento
uh who would you bet on in this
situation
I'm still going to bet on Golden State
here because all season long the
Warriors have been an abysmal Road team
the fact they lost two games on the road
is not surprising in fact they played
probably better than I thought they were
going to play in these first two Road
games especially when you consider that
Andrew Wiggins is gonna need time to get
back to being Andrew Wiggins especially
offensively he's not the player he was
before he went out
um I don't want to take anything away
from Sacramento because I came on the
show and was less than bullish about
their chances of doing anything in the
playoffs they defended in game two they
haven't defended for most of the season
they defended in game two Darren Fox you
know he took the challenge that Mike
Brown gave him to chase Steph Curry
around and he has a run with it
literally and he has been really
effective at defending him same with
Davion Mitchell Kevin heard her a lot
better than I thought he was going to be
uh defensively and offensively they're
just them like they're putting up points
and they're getting the ball out and
they're running so I don't want to take
anything away from Golden State but
I'm more confident in Sacramento's or
Golden State's eventual ability to win
on the road then I am Sacramento
Sacramento doesn't have to to be clear
like they can just win all their home
games and it can be over but I look I
think Golden State's going to win these
next two and I think we're gonna come
back to Sacramento in a game five some
place that golden state has been
50 times during the you know Curry
Thompson green era and a place that
Sacramento hasn't been before so I'm
still confident or I still believe in
Golden State but it's an uphill battle
now gotta win four of the next five and
and this Sacramento team is not just
happy to be here Chris Mannix Sports
Illustrated senior writer a couple of
weeks ago I think you were ahead of the
curve you said uh you thought the Lakers
were gonna win the west and feels like
now there's some people on the bandwagon
yours truly I like the team I thought
palinka did a wonderful job at the trade
deadline they thankfully didn't get
Kyrie but they have a good roster they
have a good team and now we look at this
team against a banged up Memphis team
you're going to see them in game three
in LA but uh how do you uh assess the
Lakers now I I do love when you're
joining my bandwagon yes it's rare that
that makes me happy Ricky Rubio this is
going to come back to bite me because I
joined you on the Laker bandwagon 100
I'm just I've just always been a
believer that you should believe when
your eyes are telling you right and
since the trade deadline the Lakers uh
are 18 and nine or No 19 and nine after
uh that game one win they won six of the
last seven going into the uh the
playoffs yeah the playing game sucked
like they didn't look good they were
lucky to get past Minnesota in that 7-8
game but I I look at that as more the
exception than the rule of how the
Lakers uh have been playing they've got
depth like Austin Reed's going for 23
including 14 in the fourth quarter
that's a you know a great performance
but that's what Austin Reed's been doing
the last couple of months like his
confidence is at like a Kobe level right
now I mean he's he's just out there
shooting and playing freely and I I
don't think that's something that can't
be duplicated over the rest of the
series and the rest of this postseason
sure rui hashimura are probably not
going to go for 29 in game two but he's
a pretty solid guy and if you're gonna
leave him wide open his numbers on catch
and shoot threes have been really good
the last couple of years and that's all
the Lakers are asking to do just stand
out there be open and make catch and
shoot threes look the Lakers won game
one was LeBron like the fourth best
player on the floor at that point he
took one shot in the fourth quarter of
that game so like you can say rui
hashimura is going to come back down to
earth well LeBron's got another level
that he's got going to go to and that
doesn't even touch Anthony Davis who
like yeah you know Anthony Davis gets
that Stinger at halftime and I'm
watching the ABC halftime show and like
they're just burying him like it's over
Anthony Davis oh God he's made a glass
and he's got to prove himself and here
we go again with Anthony Davis he comes
out of the locker room and is the best
player on the floor in the second half
of that game so look the John Moran
injury obviously changes everything from
Memphis they might get swept if John
Morant can't play the rest of these
games but moving forward like if you're
not looking at the Lakers a team that
can defend a team that shoots the three
now that has depth in scoring that in
virtually every series maybe every
series is going to have the best one-two
combination on the floor if you're not
betting on that team you're not
believing what your eyes are telling you
hi Jamal Crawford on yesterday and I
said how do you think history is going
to remember Kawhi Leonard and he said
not one of the top five players regular
season but one of the top five players
of this generation postseason how do you
think we're going I mean I'm always
amazed when he's playing I'm not amazed
when he plays well and you know here you
are with The Showdown with Kevin Durant
and he shows up big in these moments how
do you think yeah history is going to
remember him yeah that that's a good
question and a great answer from Jamal
because like Kauai might never win
another all-nba award again because just
not going to play enough games and
certainly with this new threshold for
awards he's almost certainly never gonna
win an award ever because yep the days
of Kawhi Leonard playing 65 regular
season games or more are probably gone
but you get into the playoffs and you
could probably count on a couple of
fingers maybe how many guys you might
take over Kawhi in a seven game series I
mean
his his defense has always been his
calling card and you watch Durant in
that fourth quarter what do you attempt
like a couple of shots one shot whatever
it was down the stretch didn't get a
shot in the final like six minutes or or
whatever it was uh you know that that's
huge for the for the Clippers and then
offensively the way he's grown really
since San Antonio he's just reliable
from three-point range like you give him
the ball he is going to make a positive
offensive play out of it so I agree with
Jamal
in these playoffs
I don't know if there's a guy I'd take
over him to you know I think LeBron
still lurks out there as a guy that can
change the game all by himself but both
ends of the floor for 30 plus minutes of
a playoff game I think Kawhi Leonard
might be the best player in this
postseason
[Music]
who would you take who can do two things
who can do those two things as well as
Kawhi Leonard offense defense well I
would have Giannis
then I'll be taking beat over him yes
because I know that they're going to be
available
this is a tough time to say Giannis is
definitely going to be available after
he missed the second half of game one
with that back injury uh he tried to he
tried to come back
he tried but he was hurt right I'm not
this isn't about the disparage I would
have missed a month
well Kawhi doesn't get up that high
anymore so it's not he's not uh gonna be
you wouldn't take Steph Curry over him
in the playoffs right now no and you
wouldn't take LeBron over him LeBron's
the only one that's close that's what I
said like he's
you know because of everything LeBron
can do on both ends when he dials it up
like Kawhi in a postseason game kind of
dials it up all the way right away like
he's he's that guy the moment he steps
on the floor but to have a guy that for
30 some odd minutes you can put on the
best Wing player in the opposing team
who in today's NBA is more often than
not the best player on the opposing team
whether it's what he did against Giannis
a few years ago when he was in Toronto
what he did uh what he's done already in
this series against Kevin Durant which
is probably going to continue to do
I don't know I think you get enough from
him offensively to separate him up you
know from on both ends among the greats
in this league good to talk to you as
always Chris
welcome to the bandwagon
it's going to come back to haunt me I
know it is thank you bud
you got it Chris Mannix Sports
Illustrated senior basketball writer
he's going to take Kauai I just never
know if Kwai is going to be available
now he's great in the postseason but I
just don't know if he's always going to
be available in the postseason
would I take LeBron over him yeah
but I know LeBron's going to be there
Steph Curry yes I know he's going to be
there Giannis yes
uh I would take him bead now